mesdames messieurs bon dimanche le
chemin Roxane et les milliers de
personnes qui l'emprunt chaque mois ce
sont de nouveau imposés dans l'actualité
cette semaine pendant que Québec a vous
une ressource réclame l'aide des autres
provinces pour l'accueil des migrants
irréguliers
Ottawa mise plutôt sur la renégociation
avec les États-Unis de l'entente sur les
tiers pays sûr le chef conservateur lui
estime que tout cela a assez duré et
réclame du gouvernement Trudeau la
fermeture pur et simple de Roxane d'ici
30 jours
de fermer Wacken Road c'est ce que nous
voulons tous mais il y a pas de solution
simpliste là-dedans faut la fermer pour
que notre frontière reste intègre à
travers le pays et c'est sur cela qu'on
est en train de travailler
la première chef du Parti conservateur
bonjour merci d'être avec nous
merci ce point lièvre vous avez demandé
au gouvernement cette semaine de fermer
le chemin Roxane dans les 30 prochains
jours pourquoi dans les 30 prochains
jours pourquoi cette semaine
mais premièrement juste un trou d'eau a
déjà eu 6 ans ça fait 6 ans que les gens
traversent illégalement
au chemin de Roxane donc il a eu
beaucoup de temps déjà c'est pas comme
c'est de nouveau il a un gouvernement
qui devrait contrôler nos frontières qui
étaient ce qui sont évidemment des
responsabilités fédérales et maintenant
ça devient une crise comme le premier
slogo a montré ça cause des coûts
supplémentaires pour nos services
sociaux qui ne sont pas abordables donc
je veux que le premier fasse son travail
finalement et qu'il repartent d'hommage
qu'il a causé en invitant de traverser
légalement et on établissant
l'infrastructure pour les accueillir et
le renverser pour protéger nos
frontières et pour rétablir un système
de dénigration basée sur la loi elle est
sur les entrées ordonnées on
fait ça de fermer Roxane
comment vous voyez ça
je donne ça au Premier ministre qui a un
gouvernement de 400 milliards de dollars
qu'il a une service à frontalier il y a
une service d'immigration il y a un
département de la Justice donc il
devrait pouvoir après six ans trouver
une façon de fermer le chemin Roxane et
si vous voulez que je mette je la prouve
avec avec l'évidence c'est que avant
juste un troudeau on n'avait pas ce
problème il y avait pas ses entrées
illégales avant juste un trou d'eau même
si on avait le même frontière avec les
États-Unis et on a le même entendre sur
la le troisième pays sort depuis 20 ans
mais on n'avait jamais ce problème avant
juste un trou d'eau c'est lui qui la
causé qui c'est lui qui devrait le
régler d'ici 30 jours le problème est
beaucoup plus important certains disent
que le problème est beaucoup plus le
plus important depuis que Monsieur Trump
est passé par la Maison Blanche et qu'il
a imposé des règles beaucoup plus
sévères sur certaines catégories
d'immigrants est-ce qu'il y a pas un peu
la responsabilité des Américains
là-dedans
il y a plus monsieur Trump on a un
monsieur Biden maintenant alors
Justin Trudeau tout le monde autre que
lui-même alors il a dit que c'était le
problème lié au président mais on a un
nouveau président depuis presque deux
ans alors il faut trouver une autre
excuse la frontière canadienne elle est
longue 6000 km je sais qu'il y a des
ressources effectivement comment on fait
pour s'assurer qu'on déplace pas le
problème ailleurs parce que c'est ça la
préoccupation de certains c'est ce que
Monsieur Trudeau invoqué cette semaine
quand il a répondu à votre à votre
ultimatum
c'est quand est-ce que cette frontière a
été établie il y a plus de 150 ans on a
toujours eu une langue frontière avec
les États-Unis mais avant juste être
d’eau c'était miracle on était capable
de protéger notre entière on n'avait pas
ce problème avant juste un trou d'eau
alors oui quand il y avait d'autres
gouvernements avant lui on était capable
de ne pas se voir une entrée au rock
sunrhodes aura que ce chemin et on était
capable en même temps de protéger le
reste de la frontière alors oui c'est
possible je peux lire vous êtes le chef
du Parti conservateur vous vous êtes
prétendants au poste de Premier ministre
vous l'avez dit à plusieurs reprises une
part de votre responsabilité là-dedans
qu'est-ce que vous feriez vous si vous
étiez dans la chaise du Premier ministre
pour régler la question Roxane
je le fermerai et comment vous le
fermerez
il y a plusieurs façons le gouvernement
est capable de décider qui entre dans un
pays et qui n'entre pas alors avant
Justin Trudeau c'était pas un problème
on avait un système d'immigration qui
est invité les gens de venir ici de
façon légale et moi je crois qu'on
devrait rétablir cette approche là les
gouvernements national ont le droit de
contrôler leur frontière quand je
deviens Premier ministre je vais fermer
le chemin Roxane et j'espère que Justin
Trudeau va le faire dans le prochain
jour pour que pour régler la problème
pour le bénéfice des gens qui nous
écoutent quand vous êtes je le fermerai
je contrôlerai davantage la frontière ça
veut dire comment ça veut dire que vous
repoussez les gens qui arrivent comment
concrètement sur le terrain ça se fait
comment
mais de la même façon qu'on a on l'a
fait pendant la période de covid c'est
ça qui montre combien Justin Trudeau est
ridicule quand il dit que c'est
impossible de fermer le chemin vaccin il
l'a fait pendant la période de covid il
a décidé avec raison que qu'on devrait
pas mère permettre les gens de traverser
pendant la période de Covel covid mais
soudainement il a dit non on va rouvrir
alors comment a-t-il fermé l'a-t-il
fermé pendant la période de covid si
c'est impossible pourquoi 30 jours
pourquoi vous avez dit je vous donne 30
jours et qu'est-ce qui arrive d'après
vous au bout de 30 jours quel est
l'ultimatum
mais 30 jours parce que honnêtement 30
jours c'est généreux juste un trou doit
six ans depuis qu'il a ouvert le chemin
de Roxane
ça fait c'était 2017 quand il a envoyé
son tweet il a invité les gens à
traverser illégalement il a établi à
l'infrastruction pour les accueillir
illégalement six ans il a déjà eu six
ans alors maintenant c'est c'est assez
ramenance au gros roman le gros bon sens
chez nous ramenons le gros bon sang chez
nous assez c'est assez on devrait
inviter les réfugiés et les émigrants
mais on devrait le faire de façon
ordonnée et selon la loi et en passant
je devrais les mentionner que je blâme
pas les réfugiés aux autres ils font
exactement ce que Justin Trudeau suggère
il a suggéré que les gens devraient
traverser les frontières il est
également donc les gens le font ce
projet vous l'impression que la question
de Roxane mais la position que vous avez
adopté cette semaine elle vous permet de
mieux connecter avec les québécois
c'est pas mon but mon but c'est de
protéger notre pays nous sommes un vrai
pays un pays doit avoir des frontières
et un gouvernement fédéral géré par un
bon premier ministre de vrai mener cette
responsabilité et c'est ce que je vais
faire quand je serai Premier ministre et
vous feriez quoi de l'entente sur les
tiers pays sûr doit-elle être une
renégocié comme comme l'évoque monsieur
Trudeau
peut-être mais je pense que Kudo je veux
juste blâmer Joe Biden pour le problème
que trou doit causer évidemment les
entrées au vaccin au chemin AXA m'a
commencé à 20 Biden mais
donc c'est pas Biden qui la causé et
c'est papa Biden qui est responsable
pour nos frontières le
l'entend sur les 3e pays sur est en
place depuis 20 ans 20 ans mais ça n'a
jamais été un problème avant Justin
Trudeau cependant sur les allégations
d'ingérence du gouvernement chinois dans
le processus électoral lors de la
dernière élection
on dit que l'influence certains disent
que l'influence chinoise pourrait être à
blâmer pour la défaite de 9 de vos
candidats vous en dites quoi
mais c'est pas nous qui dit qui a eu un
ingérence c'est nos services de
renseignement et ces services ont averti
juste introdo de ce problème depuis les
années et il n'a rien fait pourquoi
parce qu'il a bénéficié donc il n'a
aucun problème à permettre une
gouvernement
autoritaire étrangers se mêler dans nos
affaires parce que qui en profite mais
je vous demande pourquoi est-ce que un
gouvernement autoritaire à Pékin veut
que juste un trou d'eau reste Premier
ministre est-ce que c'est parce que
c'est parce que il est bon pour le
Canada
je vais vous lasser à prendre votre
propre décision est-ce que ça vous a
coûté des sièges d'après vous est-ce que
ça vous a fait perdre des sièges
du Parti conservateur merci d'avoir été
des nôtres
merci de m'avoir invité